what do you think consciousness is
this co this whole conversation has
impossibly difficult questions what what
what are you doing
this is so hard
uh yeah we talked about music for like
two minutes all right no i'm just no i'm
just over music i'm over music yeah i
i still like it it has its purpose no i
love music i mean music's the greatest
thing ever it's my favorite thing but i
i just like
every interview is like
what is your process like i don't know
i'm just done i can't do it i do want to
ask you about ableton live i mean i'll
tell you about ableton because ableton
is sick
no one asks no one ever asks about
ableton though yeah well because i just
need tech support mainly i can i can
help you i can help you with your
ableton tech anyway uh from ableton back
to consciousness what do you uh do you
think this is a thing that only humans
are capable of
can can robots be conscious can
like when you think about entities you
think there's aliens out there that are
conscious like it's conscious what is
consciousness this terence mckenna quote
that i've found that i [ __ ] love
am i allowed to swear on here uh yes
nature loves courage
uh you make the commitment and nature
will respond to that commitment by
removing impossible obstacles dream the
impossible dream and the world will not
grind you under it will lift you up this
is the trick this is what all these
teachers and philosophers who really
counted who really touched the
alchemical gold this is what they
understood
this is the shamanic dance in the
waterfall this is how magic is done by
hurling yourself into the abyss and
discovering it's a feather bed
yeah
and for this reason i
i do think there are no technological
limits i i think like what what is
already happening here this is like
impossible this is insane and we've done
this in a very limited amount of time
and we're accelerating the rate at which
we're doing this so i i think digital
consciousness
were uh it's inevitable and we we may
not be able to even understand what that
means
but i like curling yourself into the
abyss so we're surrounded by all this
mystery and we just keep hurling
ourselves into it like fearlessly and
keep discovering cool [ __ ]
yeah
like
i just i just think it's like
the
like who even knows if the laws are
physical the laws of physics are
probably just the current like as i'm
saying speed of light is the current
render rate it's like
if we're in a simulation they'll be able
to upgrade that like i sort of suspect
when uh
we made the james webb telescope like
part of the reason we made that is
because we had an upgrade
uh you know and so now more more of
space has been rendered so we can see
more of it now
yeah but i think humans are super super
super limited cognitively so i wonder
uh i wonder if we'll be allowed to
create more intelligent beings that can
see more of the universe as the as the
render rate is uh upgraded maybe we're
cognitively limited everyone keeps
talking about how we're cognitive
cognitively limited and ai is going to
render us obsolete but it's like you
know
like this is not the same thing as like
an amoeba becoming an alligator like
it's like if we create ai again that's
intelligent design that's literally all
religions are based on gods that create
consciousness like we are god making
like what we are doing is incredibly
profound and like even if we
uh can't compute even
even if we're so much worse than them
like just like
like like
unfathomably worse than like you know an
omnipotent kind of ai it's like we
i do not think that they would just
think that we are stupid i think that
they would recognize the profundity of
what we have accomplished are we the
gods or are they the gods in our
perspective i mean i mean we're kind of
like
it's complicated it's complicated
like but they would acknowledge the the
value
well i hope they acknowledge the value
of paying respect to the creative
ancestors i think they would think it's
cool i i i think um
i think if curiosity is is a trait that
we
uh
can quantify and put into a.i then i i
think if ai are curious then they will
be curious about us and they will not be
hateful or dismissive of us they might
you know see us as
i don't know it's like
i'm not like oh [ __ ] these dogs let's
let's kill all the dogs
i love dogs dogs have great utility dogs
like provide a lot we make friends with
them yeah we have a deep connection with
them
uh we anthropomorphize them like we have
a real love for dogs for cats and so on
for some reason even though they're
intellectually much less than us and i
think i think there's some there is
something sacred about us because it's
like if you look at the universe like
the whole universe is like
cold and dead and sort of robotic and
it's like
um
you know
ai intelligence
you know it's it's
kind of more like the universe it's like
it's like cold and
and
you know
logical and
you know abiding by the laws of physics
and
whatever but like we like we're this
like loosey-goosey weird art thing that
happened and i think it's beautiful and
um like i think even if we want i think
one of the values
if uh
consciousness is the thing
that is most worth preserving
um which i think is the case i think
consciousness i think if there's any
kind of like religious or spiritual
thing um
it should be that consciousness is
sacred
uh
like
then you know
i still think even if ai renders
obsolete and we climate change
it's too bad and we get hit by a comet
and we don't become a multi-planetary
species fast enough but like ai is able
to populate the universe like i imagine
like if i was an ai i would uh find more
planets that are capable of hosting
biological life forms and like recreate
them because we're fun to watch yeah
we're fun to watch
yeah but i i do believe that ai can have
some of the same magic
of consciousness within it
because consciousness we don't know what
it is so you know there's some kind of
it might be a different magic it might
be like a straight a strange
a strange different
right because they're not gonna have
hormones like i feel like a lot of our
magic is hormonal
kind of i i don't know i think some of
our magic is the limitations the
constraints and within that the hormones
and all that kind of stuff the
finiteness of life and then we get given
our limitations we get to some come up
with creative solutions of how to dance
around those limitations we partner up
like penguins against the cold we
we fall in love and uh and then love is
ultimately some kind of
allows us to delude ourselves that we're
not
mortal and finite and that life is not
ultimately you live alone
you're born alone you die alone and then
love is like a for a moment or for a
long time forgetting that and so like we
come up with all these creative hacks
that make life
like fascinatingly
fun
yeah yeah yeah fun yeah and then ai
might have different kinds of fun yes
and hopefully our funds intersect
intersect i think once in a while i
think there would be there there'd be a
little intersection there'd be a little
intersection of the fun
you